você já parou para pensar que neste
exato momento o grande amor da sua vida
pode estar sentado aqui nessa sala ou lá
fora em algum lugar do planeta e você
simplesmente nunca conhecer
existem estudos que apontam que apenas
11% das pessoas no mundo encontrou sua
alma gêmea eu faço parte das 89 por
cento restantes
por enquanto sempre me intrigou o que
fazia com que duas pessoas se sentissem
atraídas uma pela outra
graças à minha atividade profissional já
atende mais de mil homens e mulheres
vivendo todo tipo de relação e acredito
que o amor tem muito mais a ver com
física química biologia e até matemática
do que com lotaria mágica ou sorte o
cupido ou eros o deus do amor não é
propriamente um anjinho ao lado de
cabelos encaracolados que no splash por
quem quer emos nos apaixonar
às vezes a flecha vem ver nada
ele está mais para um deus travesso que
apronta das suas transformando a vida da
gente num verdadeiro inferno
isso porque ele obedece aos caprichos da
sua mãe
afrodite a deusa da beleza e do desejo e
ela costuma se vingar de noite toda vez
que negligenciamos com o desejo ou com
belo na nossa vida
não pretendendo desmistificar a idéia de
que o amor é misterioso e poético ao
contrário vou demonstrar que existe um
caminho mais seguro para se chegar ele
sem ter que depender da sorte e
sintetizei esse caminho através de três
princípios indispensáveis ao amor
o primeiro princípio do amor é o desejo
e ele surge a partir do nosso sistema
límbico cerebral é o considera o sistema
límbico como a nossa alma porque é ele
que faz o nosso coração disparar
quando estamos apaixonados ou a em
loucas e de raiva pelo ciúme e até
perder a alegria de viver
quando sentimos a dor de um coração
partido ela também que fica todos os
nossos valores e nossos desejos quando
essa bioquímica acontece é gerado o
desejo mas dizem por aí que o desejo que
o amor é cego
discordo cego mesmo é o desejo e
facilmente nós podemos nos deixar
enganar por ele quem aqui nunca se
deixou enganar levado apenas pelo desejo
comigo foi assim e vou te contar
minha mãe ficou viúva aos 39 anos e ela
era apaixonada pelo meu pai
ano após ano ela continua apaixonada e
diariamente ela costumava ouvir músicas
românticas em espanhol na sua vitrola
assim aquele sons foram ficando gravados
na minha memória afetiva desde a
infância até que um belo dia quando eu
tinha 19 anos
eu fui visitar uma colega de faculdade
que estava recém casada com um
estrangeiro quando cheguei na casa dela
o seu cunhado estava sentado tocando
violão e cantando em espanhol da conta
eu me senti atraída por ele pra resumir
essa história foi uma paixão que nos
levou ao altar em apenas oito meses
o relacionamento foi turbulento e cheio
de divergências culturais e de valores
mas minha alma no momento daquela cena
não tinha clareza disso e sete anos
depois nos separamos e eu cheguei a uma
primeira conclusão antes de se render
apenas ao desejo tem a clareza do que
você quer atrair imagine que você
precisa para ficar algo para comer
mas você não sabe bem o que você deseja
então você lança seu barco no mar sem o
equipamento
é necessário com muita sorte você pode
voltar de lá com meia dúzia de lambaris
e alguns crustáceos se você não tiver
sorte você pode voltar sem nada ou até
com tipos letais em formato de serey aí
de peixe espada
muita gente fica com o resultado dessa
pesca apenas para que o esforço o tempo
eo dinheiro investidos não tenha sido em
vão
lembrando quando você está preparado
para pescar e sabe o que você quer você
usa o equipamento ea escassez e vai no
local mais apropriado aumentando assim
as suas chances de encontrar o que você
deseja
lembrando apenas que os espécimes mais
raros não costumam ficar na beira do mar
pra quem é preguiçoso vai ter que
depender da sorte mesmo
essa simples atitude pode te livrar de
muitos relacionamentos que não tem nada
a ver com você
outros tóxicos e até abusivos
pode parecer óbvio mas a maioria das
pessoas sai para paquerar
sem a mínima noção do que elas realmente
desejam
e foi assim que eu cheguei ao segundo o
princípio do amor eu o desejo apenas não
é suficiente para segurar um amor para
construir um relacionamento
ao longo dos meus atendimentos
eu costumava ver pessoas que assim que
começavam a viver juntas passava a fazer
cobranças intermináveis gerando a conta
corrente que não fechava nunca alguns
até transformavam a sessão de terapia em
um verdadeiro muro das lamentações por
isso que eu cheguei esse segundo
princípio a reciprocidade
ela é importante porque além de gerar
empatia mantém o equilíbrio do
relacionamento após passar o primeiro
momento da
precisamos estar dispostos a retribuir
ao outro tudo aquilo que queremos dele
assim por exemplo se para você o
respeito à fidelidade ou até
individualidade
são valores importantes você precisa
também atribuir essa mesma moeda
ambos os parceiros precisam se sentir
recompensados pelo investimento feito no
relacionamento
o jogo do amor deve ser como um jogo de
frescobol onde os dois se divertem e nem
tem que ganhar e não como jogo de tênis
onde o importante é competir e vez e
quando consigo conheci o meu segundo
marido eu tinha clareza do que eu queria
estava disposta a conhecer alguém que
tivesse valores semelhantes aos meus e
que assim como eu também fosse separado
e tivesse filhos para facilitar a
compreensão da minha condição naquela
época fui com a amiga ouviu o marido
dela tocar sax na casa noturna quando
minha atenção foi atraída para um rapaz
que estava no bar sozinho me olhando ele
me convidou para um drinque
após as primeiras horas de conversa
depois que ele me contou do seu
insucesso no primeiro casamento
senti que havia empatia entre nós
naquela noite fomos expulsos do bar pelo
garçom porque o sol já estava nascendo
estávamos os dois dispostos a refazer
nossa vida afetiva em outras bases havia
reciprocidade entre nós dois anos depois
nos casamos e fomos morar juntos com os
nossos filhos do primeiro casamento e
felizes realizamos muitos sonhos em
comum e inclusive tivemos uma filha
mas como disse renato russo não a música
se lembra quando a gente chegou um dia
que
acreditar que tudo era pra sempre sem
sabe que o pra sempre sempre acaba
acabou dez anos depois quando eu
observei que os nossos objetivos de vida
já não eram mais congruentes e sim
divergentes e chegam a segunda conclusão
quando os propósitos de vida de inveja
em nosso coração vagueia nos levando
para outras direções
a partir daquele momento passei
aprofundar os meus conhecimentos sobre o
comportamento humano ea observar os
tipos de relacionamento bem sucedidos à
minha volta e pensava será que existe
alguma coisa em comum nesses
relacionamentos
foi quando eu descobri o elo que faltava
para que o amor tivesse êxito o terceiro
e mais importante princípio do amor
vocês querem saber qual é sim afinidade
ela une pessoas em torno de um mesmo
propósito de vida
palma disse que a afinidade é uma ponte
que conduz ao abrigo seguro do
parentesco
acredito que ela se dá entre tipos de
personalidade semelhantes ou
complementares e não entre as
conflitantes
fui em busca de teorias psicológicas que
embasasse esse meu terceiro princípio
analisando desde hipócrates com a teoria
dos quatro elementos passando por um
guia com os tipos psicológicos cheguei
ao estudo de ellen ficha com a sua
biologia da personalidade
segundo ela existe um mecanismo
biológico por trás das nossas escolhas
amorosas
assim ela classificou a nossa
personalidade em quatro tipos um baseado
em dois neurotransmissores a dopamina ea
serotonina e dois hormônios a
testosterona e estrogênio
todos nós temos essas mesmas substâncias
agindo no nosso cérebro a diferença é a
quantidade que cada um fica disponível
fazendo com que a gente tenha esse ou
aquele comportamento assim pessoas que
são movidas a dopamina como eu são
chamadas de exploradores e eles são vive
buscando novidades adoram um desafio são
mentalmente flexíveis e motivados e se
atraem por outros exploradores os que
são movidos pela serotonina são os
construtores são cautelosos persistentes
são disciplinados e tradicionais e se
atrair por outros construtores já as
pessoas movidas pela testosterona são os
diretores
eles têm um raciocínio lógico são
racionais analíticos e práticos e se
atrai pelos negociadores que são movidos
pelo estrogênio e por isso eles são
holísticos idealistas intuitivos e
teóricos e se atrai pelos diretores
esses dois últimos tipos são
complementares
a essa altura vocês já devem ter se auto
analisando por aí não é mesmo para saber
o tipo de vocês e um de nós tem um tipo
só exclusivamente cada um tem um segundo
tipo auxiliar o que facilita e amplia as
possibilidades de combinação portanto
ninguém precisa sair daqui rompido com
seu atual relacionamento mas vale a pena
eu recomendo fazer o teste
nesses tempos de amores líquidos e
virtuais onde podemos descartar uma
pessoa com apenas um clique
a afinidade é fundamental para que o
amor ganha consistência e tenha
durabilidade
certamente existem várias outras
motivações que levam as pessoas a fazer
escolhas amorosas como a admiração
condição socioeconômica e até o medo da
solidão
por isso após todos esses anos
analisando os relacionamentos bem
sucedidos a minha volta eu cheguei a uma
terceira conclusão afinidade a sua
melhor escolha
durante a nossa caminhada amorosa
passamos por diversas distrações e não a
dessas podemos ficar a vida toda
enquanto o nosso grande amor perambula
por aí a nossa procura na vastidão do
planeta atualmente tem evitado me
distrair enquanto não chega com onde eu
quero estar porque eu sei que é lá que o
meu grande amor também estará
pode ser que a gente não consiga
capturar a felicidade amorosa numa rede
de pesca
mas devemos usar tudo que sabemos sobre
a natureza humana de modo que quando o
amor chegar
não deixemos escapar a propósito tem
algo explorador aí na platéia
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]